foreign
a few days ago we all witnessed a huge
downfall in the crypto Market due to
which many cryptos faced a lot of
backlash
yet there is one cryptocurrency that has
been getting a lot of attention drawn to
itself
and that is the Sheba Inu coin
every day the hype surrounding this
crypto is increasing and there is a lot
of interest in learning more and more
about this cryptocurrency
hey everyone I'm Douglas and I welcome
you to this video from Simply learn
about Shiba Inu coin
in this video we will explore Shiba
inucoin
and we'll go through really exciting
Concepts and components revolving around
it
first we'll take a look at the origin of
Shiba Inu coins
then we will go over what is Shiba
inucoin
then we will explore how it is different
and unique from Dodge Coin
then we will discuss why it is so
popular
lastly we will explore the future of
Sheba inucoin
okay so let's get started with the video
so what is the origin of Sheba Inu coin
the Sheba inucoin was created in August
2020 by an anonymous person calling
themselves ryoshi an Indian
it was intended to be an altcoin of
Dodge Coin which itself was an altcoin
of Bitcoin
this meme coin was named after the
Japanese dog breed Shiba Inu
it feels like the shiba inucoin was
willed into existence and is now
insanely popular among crypto exchanges
through the power of its many followers
memes and a very cute dog now that we
know how it originated let's take a look
at what is Shiba Inu coin Shiba inucoin
is a decentralized community building
cryptocurrency or we can say an
experiment developed within the Shiva
Inu ecosystem and built on top of the
ethereum blockchain network like many
other coins
it is a meme coin launched as a rival of
Dodge Coin a Dodge killer
both Dodge Coin and Shiba coin were made
in a humorous manner but Shiba coin has
already taken over some Dodge Coin
markets
and Rising as a popular choice among
investors
especially after market crashes of
cryptos like Bitcoin and ethereum
so what is the difference between Shiva
inucoin and Dodge Coin
although Shiba inucoin and Dodge Coin
are meme coins and share the same tree
of origin
these two coins differ a lot from each
other
the first difference is the shiba coin
is a token and Dodge Coin is a currency
let's take a look at a few more major
differences
with regard to the development Shiba
inucoins are sheb coins are built on and
powered by the ethereum network
whereas Dodge Coin was developed using
the same technology as Bitcoin
next is use cases
sheepcoin is still working upon price
more due to its popularity than utility
on the other hand Dodge Coin has
established itself to some extent
as a medium for online payments
then there is the value according to
coin market cap the current value of
sheepcoin
is
0.0007378 dollars
while the value of Dodge Coin is
0.261711 dollars lastly is availability
availability of sheepcoin today is 394
million and for Dodge Coin it is 130
billion
so now this may raise the question why
did she become so popular
Shiba inucoin is majorly popular for two
reasons
Tesla founder Elon Musk recently tweeted
that he would like to own a Sheba pup
that hyped the crypto market and Prices
rose by 300 percent
prices later fell about 40 percent after
the founder of ethereum blockchain
network vitalik buterin donated 50
trillion Shiba Inu coins to the Indian
government for the corporate Relief Fund
of an Indian crypto entrepreneur Sandeep
naival
so now that we know about Shiba inucoin
and its Concepts let's take a look at
the future of Shiba inucoin
though sheepcoin is only known as a meme
coin its increasing popularity and
people's interest in participating in it
is pointing toward a different but
bright future
according to investingcube.com the
sheepcoin is predicted to rise again
although there isn't much movement among
its token and its value active buyers
could help its value rise
the value could rise to
0.0001040 in a more active buyer's
market
although it may not appear to be a
significant amount due to its popularity
in the future it could have a
significant influence over large
investors of the crypto Market
so that ends our discussion about what
Shiba Inu coin is and that brings us to
the end of this video if I've missed
anything important please do let me know
in the comments section below I hope you
enjoyed the video and have a better
understanding of what Shiba inucoin is
if you like the video please do hit the
like button thanks for watching this
video and stay tuned for more updates
and videos from Simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here